I think minor questioning if they're
good enough to actually go out on date
it's much easier for guys to get online
and engage in corn and again not be
engaged in the real world if that girl
rejects them they feel horrible about
themselves and it's it's tough for them
to go back in and try again the person
that loses everything is always going to
be trying to appease the one that gains
everything the man is the lead like he
is the one that takes charge today's
topic we're talking about sexless men so
a study published in the art Archives of
sexual behavior found that the number of
sexually inactive young adults has
increased in recent years a survey
conducted by the General Social Survey
which found that the percentage of men
under 30 who have not had had sex in the
past year has tripled since 2008. a
study published in Jama Pediatrics which
found that fewer teens are having sex
than in previous generations a study
found in the Journal of adolescent
health health which which found that
social media use is associated with a
decrease in sexual activity among
adolescents according to a 2017 study
the number of sexually inactive men in
the U.S has tripled in the past decade
the percentage of men aged 18 to 29 who
have not had had sex in the past year
increased from 9.5 percent in 2008 to 28
in 2018. there are a number of potential
reasons for this trend including the
rise of Technology social media and
video games which can be addictive and
time consuming economic factors such as
lack of job opportunities and financial
insecurity may also Inc may also
contribute to men delaying marriage and
sexual activity changes in gender norms
and expectations as well as a shift
towards more casual dating and hookup
culture may also be factors this trend
is not not unique to the U.S where there
are similar patterns in other countries
including the UK and Japan some experts
argue that the trends towards sexual
inactivity is not necessarily a negative
and may reflect a broader shift towards
a greater emphasis on personal
fulfillment and self-care
so according to the article the number
of sexless men under 30 has tripled in
the last decade why do you guys think
that's happening
so
I don't know about the US yeah
I think in the UK young people are
having sex more I just think
we're not having as much kids like as
the previous generation I feel like
people were having kids younger or
having a lot of children I feel like
we're just not having kids we're having
sex
I want to have kids so you think they're
like lying when they're surveyed about
it I don't know about them about the
lion yeah but
from being in the UK and how I know guys
that you know are out here I don't think
men have become like sexist at all
I think sorry try to call you but you
can speak after me I think also there is
a massive change in confidence
in men I don't know what happened with
this gender thing but also it's there's
a massive impact when man is confused
and it's playing in their confidence
like I think the generation right now
the kids that I'm seeing right now
there's a massive difference between
them and the generation that I know so
boys what do you think caused that
um there's a lot of culture you know
even the songs that you hear like six
figure blah blah blah I think mine are
questioning if they're good enough to
actually go out on dates and take girls
out and you know be with these type of
girls that they fancy or they have to
settle for something that they're not
which most of men do but I think there's
a massive crisis I would say that's
happening to the Young Generation and
it's the whole songs the culture
everything that's happening contributing
to The Confident of the young boys right
now comparing to the generation before
and it's a bit shocking yeah so you
think that masculinity was celebrated
before and it's not now I'm just trying
to paraphrase 100 I definitely think so
um yes and it's funny enough even I
think also a lot of men are put in a lid
to who they are and what they need and
what they want and their identities been
really like there's a crisis of their
identity because of what like the
conversation that we're having and the
songs and everything the whole culture
is definitely suppressing that a hundred
percent
I definitely think there is a bit of a
crisis of masculinity going on with a
lot of young men where I mean if I think
of someone my age we have so many
strong male role models
and we didn't have the distraction of
this little device in our hands that
just sucked in all of our
potential almost as men and the humans
being as human beings and now men don't
have their role model so they almost
don't know how to be there's a backdrop
I guess of the metoo movement a lot of
genuine movements that needed to happen
and I think it's left a lot of men
discombobulated how they approach women
should they approach women what's
appropriate you know if you think a lot
of our parents probably met in Social
settings or you know through families
Etc but certainly the social aspect of
meeting people at the gym at the pub at
the bar I think a lot of men are
frightened to do that some of it is
societal like this I guess some people
see it as an attack on masculinity and
some of it is the men themselves failure
Thomas move with the modern times say
withdrawn into their computer games
they've withdrawn into this world where
they're almost just with themselves or
with their peers they've forgot the art
of actually engaging in conversations
chatting people up and doing stuff and I
think also another aspect is I think
we're a bit in the victim culture a
little bit in life as well where people
see himself as victims and Paul me and
almost the world owes them something I'm
sure there are a lot of and I don't mean
to be bad when I say but a lot of angry
men who seem that they by default should
just have stuff without having to put
the work in so it's almost like an
entitlement with guys because they're
not putting the work in they don't know
how to or they're scared to do it as a
result a lot of them are unintentionally
sexless I don't think they want to be
but I think it's unintentionally so
there's so many different factors that
are contributing to it especially more
so with men and then I guess there's
also the factor of women going for that
top 20 or the top 30 of men as we see of
these Tinder studies so most men are not
going to pass that standard anymore so
they're going to be left their sort of
sort of scratching theirs thinking what
can I do and a lot of them are choosing
to have drawn I think it's quite
dangerous as well you've seen it with a
lot of the shooting and stuff that's
happened in America they can become
quite angry and quite disaffected and it
can become quite dangerous for society
can you expound a little bit more what
you said that you said phones are
ruining men's potential yeah because
phones are this illusion of life but
it's not real so if you're always got
head in your phone or you've got your
head in video games how the hell do you
how the hell do you become who you're
born to be how the hell do you
you know get the level of Charisma the
level of confidence you need to be
always on the phone it's not a real
world you know go and talk to that woman
at a bar go and talk to that woman on
the street go and engage with an actual
human being rather than your phone it's
very easy I think to be buried in your
phone and the more you do it the more
disengaged you are from actual real
world where you need to speak to people
well you can't blame them it's actually
there's so many
there's so many different factors that
are contributing to them needing almost
I guess they feel they need to disengage
from society safer to be corn as well do
what access to Corn how easy it is
yeah I think that exactly yeah and again
that's another aspect of your phone and
Technology it's much easier for guys to
get online and engage in corn and again
not be engaged in the real world and
then get into this unrealistic world of
what
you know intimacy is for them intimacy
if it's just born that's not intimacy
that's just one side of it but rural
intimacy is engage in its share and it's
been vulnerable it's allowing yourself
to be seen and to see others and they're
not engaging in that anymore in that
same way do you think that's true for
men and for women I think more so
familiar to speaking about this before
everyone came in I think it's genuinely
harder for men because men have to graft
no one's coming to save a man I think
society would happily step over a man's
corpse and you say what 75 of
homelessness is men something like again
similar stat when it comes to Suicide I
don't think Society cares about men in
fact people probably laugh oh men
they're not having sex oh it's just
funny you know so there's all these
different things you know and I think
and because I do a lot of advocacy for
men I think for mice my stances men need
to be responsible for the state of their
lives I don't necessarily think Society
owes them anything I'd love Society to
care about men to care about masculinity
to see the value that men bring to the
world but Society may not in fact the
trend seems to be going the other way I
want men to start actually looking what
can I be responsible for let me put my
phone away let me put down Call of Duty
let me actually start to engage I know
that especially for younger people is a
bit of a mindful because what was normal
for my generation chatting up a girl on
the street or wherever it might be for
some people might be seen as some sort
of attack almost that's what Society
said but I think men need to almost
stand in their courage and just go for
it and I think if they can do it with
Charisma with respect they can start to
engage but men are checking out and I
think the
their amplification to that disaster is
not to mention the fact that
relationships break down there are a lot
of men from single parent families a lot
of these things you know that also the
absence of a father okay because it's
really serious yeah it plays a massive
part yeah and then these men are raised
by women and they're
a bit angry you know and they're just
like raising them to be scared you know
they're not raising them to be
you know men you know they're raising
them from a woman point of view that
she's been used and abused by men so
he's kind of lost his identity
that that's playing the massive part
sorry the survey well is it speaking
about a specific age group
um the young men mostly like between up
to 29. okay because I totally agree with
what you guys are saying when with the
younger guys but something that I've
personally noticed out on the street is
that the older guys that now have
families and have children they're the
ones you see during the day pushing the
buggies and with two free kids on the
street so where roles are reversed maybe
now the men are tired spending all day
with the kids and then during the night
when the wife comes home or the both
both of them are at home they're like
you know what I'm really tired I just
don't want to have anything for men
that's what I that's what I'm seeing on
the streets maybe the roles have been
reversed where usually would be the
woman I gotta I gotta be a bitly
disagree I don't know men are tired to
have sex just after even speaking to
like divorce attorneys um like the a
common complaint is that men um they
have two kids and then the wife stops
sleeping with them and I've talked to
like different attorneys in the U.S
because I'm doing a documentary on the
court system here and I've talked to
different um divorce attorneys in the US
and the UK and it's the same that sounds
more realistic because like the women
are like my body's not the same he
probably doesn't see me the same and
they just let go but guys know they
actually they want that they want to
sleep with you after you've had kids
because you're the person that they
married and all those things but I think
women just think because I've given him
kids he's not gonna want anything else
do you think that's unfair to man 100
yeah 100 because at the end of the day
men needed more
you know yeah yeah what do you guys
think why um are so many more men
sexless so like I've been coaching this
stuff now for 10 years and I see a lot
of guys they go and try to get better
with this stuff a lot of the pickup
artists teachings are misleading and
they don't work and then they just fall
into some kind of victim ideology right
so they think okay I'm gonna just fall
into red pill and resent women and hate
women and women are the enemy or they
think well I don't look like a model so
that's why I can't get girls like the
whole black pill stuff or they go to
mgtow and they say I'm not gonna even
bother dating and a lot of guys are
already self-conscious about their
height or about how old they are about
how much money they have and we were
talking before the show like we both
coached a lot of guys guys come in to
interactions just assuming like they're
not good enough for for whatever reasons
and then it becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy because they have a negative
mindset and they go down this kind of
negative spiral and then they give up
because they don't have any other
options there's no like light at the end
of the tunnel and they try to do these
things and there's also this unrealistic
standard like on Instagram and stuff
like that where you just people like
this is all perfect and this and that
and so guys are trying to compare
themselves to that and they're like well
this isn't for me so a lot of guys are
just be become more and more on the
sidelines just spectating other guys
right and so it's kind of like feast or
famine like once I teach you how to how
to get a proper mindset and do all the
system properly what changes what do you
teach them I tell them to think that
they're at 100 out of 100 at all times
and there's a brick wall between them
and the external things that happen so
if they get rejected or they get
insulted or anything like that their
value stays at 100 because they're
driving it from internally they're not
letting people's reactions and people's
responses Define their worth and then
also I tell them to assume they got the
girl before they go approach like in
public and that makes a huge huge
difference like he was saying he focuses
really heavily on the mindset that's
like most of the battle right there's
still tons of strategic elements but if
the guy is thinking that he's not good
enough and he's trying to win the girl
over he's already coming at it from the
wrong angle and girls pick up on that
right away and they think okay this guy
is low value because he thinks that I'm
way above him so I'm not I don't teach
guys to think they're better than the
girls just think they're good enough for
any girl and still keep working on
themselves and better themselves as much
as possible but that's an empowering
message and we usually get clients that
are that are virgins or divorcees or
anything like that we get them late like
in the first week and you saw on the on
the boot camp like a lot of those guys
are never taking girls home before and
part of it is getting them to believe in
themselves but the other part of it is
giving them the proper strategy to know
how to navigate through the whole system
because there can be bottlenecks any
step of the way like guys are using
random Tinder pictures they're not going
to get many matches if they get a match
they're going to send wrong messages if
they get a phone number they're going to
send their own texts and so it's very
hard for them to make it through the
whole process and they get deflated and
then they just give up and then they
just go to these other side movements
and they just all like sit on these
forums and watch these creators that
just victimize everyone I think that's
very sad because a lot of these guys
just need proper coaching like you saw
like a lot of a lot of clients that I
get Bounce from coach to coach and they
didn't get anywhere but they weren't
being given the proper mindset of the
proper system and then when you give
them that the results are just almost
instant what do you think starts the
problem though so it's like if if they
went to these forums or to these YouTube
channels or whatever like something had
to start it where it's different today
than it was 50 years ago what do you
think that is I think you know just with
with the Advent of of social media and
stuff like that and there's there's just
so much like like this Tinder statistics
right it's like if guys aren't using
professional pictures the first thing we
do when a guy signs up for my my week
programs we get in professional pictures
and then Liz and some other girls on the
team pick the top five and then we apply
face app so they're going from like
average photos to Pro photos to the best
five Pro photos to the faceapped
versions and now they're getting like a
night and day difference in the quantity
and quality of matches whereas you know
before they might have just put up
whatever pictures didn't get the result
and then they see their friend maybe
like one of their cool guy friends he's
getting a lot of girls but they don't
know how to navigate that properly but
then when they look on social media they
see you know all these perfect looking
people and they say well I'm not perfect
looking right now I have these flaws and
people have these different handicaps
they place on themselves where they are
cognizant of all these different flaws
they have and then they think that that
makes them not good enough for the girls
and then that causes the rejection and
then that like reinforces the belief and
then it just continues in a cycle right
and people are you know not many people
are called approaching anyways like even
even in your Generation stuff like that
no but it's gotten even less common yeah
much less and with covid and stuff like
this you know not many people were going
out and I I think that even once like
night venues and stuff reopened not as
many people go out anymore and a lot of
clients I work with their ego is like
very tied to approaching a female in
public so if that girl rejects them they
feel horrible about themselves and it's
it's tough for them to go back in and
try again and then if that rejection
happens again and it keeps it's like
it's like a negative momentum and then
they they just usually give up so my job
is to to show them like look you you can
totally do this and show them real
tangible results and that starts a
positive momentum and then they end up
with a place of options and they can
pick the best one for their girlfriend
something like this what do you what do
you think about the men that say they're
afraid to approach because of the metoo
movement
I mean that's a very real thing like I
live in Brazil that stuff's not really
going on over there yet but in the
western Nations it's it's a really bad
thing I just did a video on my Channel
about like in Scotland if you're talking
about like a sexual conquest and a woman
over here is you can be sent to jail you
can be sent to jail yeah it's like a new
thing why yeah and in England too like I
I correct me if I'm wrong but like if
you like cat call go on the street you
can get in trouble now right you can
Google it I don't know I'm pretty sure
that like yeah but it depends like I
have to be something like
I don't know it depends they won't
arrest you they won't arrestable offense
no it does it does it says this
legislation
wait this led this legislation will
criminal criminalize Acts including cat
calling and making offensive gestures
and walking too closely behind something
at night yes like the Scotland thing
it's if you brush up against someone and
I've been in tons of nightclubs right so
I spent a lot of my time in my life for
better or worse but you know
inadvertently you're going to be
brushing up against people when you're
packed in into a club and that's I can
put you in jail now in Scotland if you
brush up against someone so what do you
say to guys that are in countries with
laws like that do you tell them not to
approach or what's your what's your
solution as a dating coach I mean if
they I tell them to move if they can I
mean that's pretty extreme but like in
Australia for instance like they have a
new thing where women can change their
mind about consent during sex
and that's you know I have Australian
clients and and they're just terrified
they don't even want to get in a sexual
situation because there's no one there
to witness that so it's just he said she
said right and they're going to take the
side of the girl in a lot of the cases
I'm not saying that like bad stuff
doesn't happen but it makes guys very
apprehensive same with the Scotland
stuff guys were already afraid to go and
approaching now they don't want to have
legal trouble right so as these
countries and what they're trying to do
is combat harassment of women these are
real problems but when they impose these
very strict kind of lockdown measures
then it turns men away from speaking and
leads to the statistics
I'm curious um because you've lived like
everywhere yeah what is your experience
dating in different countries so I lived
in Poland and Ukraine and I often talk
on my channel that the the women are
just much more family oriented it's
almost almost like the US like 50 years
ago so it's like they're more like
feminine elegant
um kind of stronger moral system looking
for kind of family stuff like that
on on the flip side of the coin they
take longer to hook up with which was
annoying right like in Ukraine it would
take like two to five dates to actually
hook up with a girl added situations
where I'd be on a fourth date in public
and they weren't ready to kiss yet which
I've never encountered anywhere else but
there's not a lot of this you know
um kind of me too stuff that's happening
in the US and happening in in the UK and
stuff like that but again these are very
real problems that need to be addressed
but when they say that you can't speak
about
you know hooking up with a girl with an
earshot of another woman or you can't
brush up against someone even if it was
an accident or stuff like this it starts
to blur the line between you know guys
just living their life versus
potentially encountering trouble and
guys want to err on the side of caution
a lot of cases and the things we've
already discussed about how guys are
already apprehensive that adds to it and
they just figure you know I'm not gonna
even bother with that I'm just gonna
watch corn I guess or stuff like this
that was interesting so you really think
that the metoo movement has contributed
to male sexless sexlessness yes they
don't want the rest yeah because I
because I have access to like thousands
of clients and I hear these things all
the time and you know the guys in
Australia
a lot of them couldn't even leave
because of the you know during the
pandemic but they're really terrified
about getting in a situation where a
girl later says hey I changed my mind
about consent and then what happens from
there right or or a guy you know
approaching a girl and she doesn't like
it maybe in the UK is he now gonna get
in trouble right so
as we said not many people were called
approaching to begin with but when you
put these kind of restrictions on guys
are even more intimidated right because
now there's not just rejection there's
also legal consequences has that ever
happened to any of your clients or
someone you know
um getting in trouble for for no I can't
think of any any instances but I think
it's more of a it just makes people gun
shy yeah it's
bad yeah yeah they don't want to you
know just the fact that that exists and
makes them just not want to even be part
of that so like why you know they don't
want to put their freedom on the line or
something like that to get a hookup yeah
that's kind of because again I'm doing
the documentary on the court system here
and I'm starting to like learn
um you don't even have to be married
it's a crazy thing it's just with a kid
um just the that guys go through
um especially with getting access to
their kids and they can get a lot of
false accusations because here
um they're literally paid they're given
free counsel if you accuse a guy of
assault and a lot of the centers here
know that so they encourage the women to
do it
um yeah and even though it doesn't
happen to every guy I have like
listening to these stories I'm like if I
was a guy I would be so I've heard a lot
of stories like that from clients where
like basically like like women that
cheat for instance if the the husband
finds out like I've heard of a lot of
situations where the guy gets screwed
because the woman just says you know the
guy that hooked up the woman just says
like it was non-consensual just so she
can save the marriage and there's no
consequence on the woman again I'm not
saying like sexual assault doesn't
happen and it's not a real problem but
it's like a nice little like roll of the
dice in in a bunch of cases where I know
people specifically where you know it's
like a real danger even even in the U.S
like a guy I had a client where he he
basically like
um had sexually grow in Las Vegas in a
hotel room and she said I paid for the
room like stayed the night and he said
I'm gonna leave and she ran down and
said oh you know he he graped me
basically and you know situations like
that or if they cheat and then the
partner finds out it's just very easy to
say it wasn't consensual so they can
save the marriage and they don't care
what happens to the guy's life right and
then it just becomes a he said she said
yes
curious for the girls if you were in the
position of guys where the laws were
against you I wouldn't just say
something about it good it's interesting
right
and so a lot of people do mention toxic
masculinity but I definitely think the
crisis that's happening and I can see it
it's if I label it is from toxic
feminist feministy I can't really say
the word problem because how do you how
do you expect people to express
themselves when they're scared men boys
are so scared to express themselves to
approach you but the main complaint from
all of my girlfriends or the people that
I know is the man or not being men
enough yeah they're not like literally
approaching exactly but look they're
created yeah but then when we have laws
like that how can because I'm just
thinking if I was in their point of view
and you guys can tell me if you agree or
disagree but I would be really hesitant
if yeah and then also We complain about
men that wanting to get married but if
you look at the lows in here in the west
I won't get married why would I will get
married and like rest
fifty percent of my income mainly I make
the most out of that income and I don't
think that's fair as well there is there
is a privilege for women and there's a
man privilege as well and I think it's
not even marriage it's um it's just
having a kid exactly that's the crazy
thing I just talk to this guy um the
other day and he wasn't legally married
he just had a kid here
um and what she did was she um went to
like a woman's shelter and basically at
the women's shelter they tell the girls
like what to say about the guy based on
his background I know he's some of these
people yeah and so um for him he was
Muslim and she basically said that
everything she did the last 10 years she
didn't actually consent to doing because
it was under his control like control
allegedly even though she was fine with
it while they were married yes and then
they don't really get a fair shot in
court yeah and and it took him over a
year to actually get to go to court so
he didn't see his kid for a year with no
evidence yeah yeah and that's normal
yeah it's normal and you know what's fun
funny I think things are changing now
after Amber hurts yeah you know I think
the court and people and judges are kind
of like looking for more evidence and
then thinking okay maybe Are there women
are using this listen I stand up for
women I love women but I think also
abusing men I don't stand for it I think
there's have to be a balance between men
femininity and masculinity and you have
to honor each other you know what you
say is that balance isn't it because I
think there was a movement at one point
where it was believe all women which
goes completely against our tenants of
actual you know innocent unto proven
guilty it was just if a woman says it
then it's and I get it where it's come
from like you said earlier I mean you
know there's been a lot of historical
wrongs against women so there was a real
natural need to you know redress that I
think the pendulum is just swung so full
of to the other way where it's like
everyone's suffering men are suffering
but now women actually suffering because
there are like you say a lot of your
friends single because men are terrified
and I I I I I get the cries from some
quarters in society where people say
it's a deliberate thing to actually
completely dismantle relationships
because that almost seems the only
logical explanation is like this almost
like this real concerted effort to
completely dismantle marriage because
that's the only way you can explain it
to a certain extent isn't it because
some of the laws are so crazy so stupid
I'm so Sinister there is like that is
not fostering proper relationships
proper marriage and we can see the stats
of you know especially boys from single
parent families I mean my God from crime
to health to life chances to every stat
goes against them so why are we a
society pushing this real almost like an
agenda to split people up have you ever
thought about it how it changes the
Dynamics of relationships because when
you think about it if you're okay if
you're in a deal right with someone and
one party gains everything by leaving
and one party loses everything by
Leading leaving the person that loses
everything is always going to be trying
to appease the one that gains everything
and so and so I feel like that's why we
get we get
um phrases like she wears the pants in
the relationship yeah because happy wife
happy life yeah yeah because 80 of
relationships are in this oh sorry 80 of
divorces are initiated by women right
women I mean it's no surprise guys would
be terrified isn't it yeah Paul just
going back to what you said about
um you know like women that flee from
men and will make up this story and
stuff like that in the UK it is so easy
to do that it's so easy to say you know
um I'm in this situation like for
example that person that you know they
said I was with a Muslim guy he done
this this and this it's so easy for
women to do that for women to go to
shelters and for men it's like is there
not even had like at all well it's
cousin Family Court I'm learning about
this now so I might butcher it but it's
up to the discretion of a judge
um so normally like if you go to
Criminal Court you you have to convince
a jury and that's a little and it's
based on evidence we're in family court
it's based on a balance of probabilities
so they're not even 100 sure if he's
guilty in the UK this is even before the
court like yeah yeah like if you could I
don't really know like the lines and
stuff but if you for example said to
your doctor I mean this even though you
might not be you could say I'm in this
relationship this person is like you
know domestic violence I have a child
you can leave that night and then
they'll take you to like a refuge or
something like it's so easy for women
I'm not saying that there's not women
out there that actually do need that
because they do but there's also women
that are taking advantage of that and
once you get to that point you can get
benefits you can get housing like
there's so much more but before the
court I'm saying like before the court
and they kick him out of the house
because that's what he was telling me he
was saying you first go to either a
teacher or a doctor and then they take
you to the women's shelter and they tell
you what to say and then one call um to
the police they have the women's shelter
instructs you on what to say to the
police so he's gone basically yeah the
police can take them the next day yeah
yeah and so um one like there's one guy
who got one call and it was I forgot
what exactly the words he said but it
was basically like get out of the house
and he still has to pay for the mortgage
on the house because it's in his name
and then he slapped with 1500 in child
support a month easily and then he lost
his job because he was so yeah you know
I mean he just lost his kids and
everything he owned I have one client
that basically
um he built the whole you know financial
situation the wife was staying home with
the kids and he came home one day early
from work and his wife was with another
guy and you know the guy was like
running out the back door whatever but
what's interesting is that she ended up
getting the whole house like almost full
custody of the kids and like totally
ruined his life but he didn't do
anything wrong right just the way the
system is set up and that doesn't mean
like oh everyone needs to go mgtow now
and don't ever get married but that
really like calls into question here
that was not even something he did you
know he didn't do anything wrong but the
courts are going to side with the woman
in most cases in the western world yeah
and that's it's hard because
it there's not really a way to avoid it
out here because even the guy that I
talked to the other day he wasn't
legally married it was just exactly you
don't even need to be married like it's
just it's so easy like as soon as you go
through the doctor that that day they
will send you to like
the
do you know someone that's happened to
yeah that's why tell me tell me what
happened
um so I know somebody that was in just
in a normal relationship no problem
whatever but they needed housing
yeah like there's nothing to do with a
partner so they just created their own
partner in their head got into a refuge
no way waited a year was in temporary
housing
and then got into a flat so don't even
need like any type of everything you
don't need evidence like now nowadays
they're cracking onto it more but I know
back then it was easy if I said I'm in a
really they don't even need to know the
guy if I just and I just literally they
don't even listen to me a fake person
and I'm not saying that I haven't done
dust or live at home I'm just saying
example right people but that's how easy
it is in the UK like people take
advantage of the system
so yeah the number of abuse allegations
increased uh 200 percent when they
implemented that law I think it was
2013.
um so yeah because like you're getting
hit you okay yeah I'm not saying that
that doesn't happen though I'm not being
insensitive but I'm just being real do
you guys think okay if the roles were
reversed and we had those repercussions
for being with men yeah would you change
your behavior I I want to talk to anyone
you want to talk to anyone you know
what's funny I think I'm I'm curious I
haven't heard from you yet so I want to
hear eggshells I would be walking on
eggshells I would be so paranoid it'd be
paranoid to the point where it's like
it's not even a point in talking to
anyone I'll just do me focus on me
someone comes my way they come my way I
wouldn't even go out looking for people
because I would be so scared of what
could come from it legally some guys
um put ring all over their apartment so
they can't say that anything that was
consensual like wasn't consensual yeah
but then wouldn't that be um
like they're recording it without your
content I have no idea if that's legal
yeah you can't Record sex acts yeah
that's where they draw the line right so
like I I advise clients to have like you
know at least they kind of outside your
house or in situations where it is legal
so you can show I actually spoke to a
lawyer about this because because I've
been sleeping a lot of girls I said how
do I protect myself and he said I'll
just send a text did you have a good
time I said that's not guaranteed
they're going to respond even if they
did right so an objective empirical
account that shows like this person's
living on good terms and this and that
I've never had any accusation luckily
with with all these girls but I have
plenty of clients that have and a lot of
times like I mentioned before it's
because the person cheated and then they
just want to save the marriage and it's
like you know there's no consequence for
doing that really if the girl is lying
which is unfortunate but I think proceed
with caution
I don't know like in some countries it's
a bit more strict I feel like even
though you the UK might say some of
these things I haven't actually heard
them until today can I just say
something also
I think also in the west and it's
naturally right a lot of a lot of men go
after
these type of women and they they like
them it's attractive these type of women
that will
how would I say the word
crazy no no they will F them up okay
yeah because they're attractive they're
sexy they're whatever it is but you
don't understand you turned around like
you created that monster woman have to
be looking that certain way wait that
certain way blah blah blah she needs
and then this woman become your worst
enemy because this woman is a gold
digger you have to keep maintaining her
looks her you know going out every night
in these type of restaurants and she
will use you and abuse you but we a man
most of the time aren't attracted to
this type of woman and they complain
about what these women do for them but
they don't honor a lot of nice girls
that they don't look like 10 out of 10.
it's the same reverse too right like
women that women don't want a nice guy a
hundred percent it's it's natural people
exactly it is attractive I also we do I
also think that man you you really don't
know what someone's gonna do when
they're when they're scorned when
they're pissed off and I think you can
see a different side of people when
there's a breakup but that's what I'm
saying and that's the thing it's not
that like women are worse than men or
men are worse than women wait but it's
that women are given the tools to
destroy men if they so want to yeah I am
interesting to see what type of world
would be living in when that's been
reversed yeah well I mean you could go
back a hundred years ago it wasn't the
no-fault divorce started in
90s 70s I don't remember but 100 years
ago it wasn't like that oh look at the
east east let's see that was one of the
problems because when men did have that
power Society saw some men is abusing it
so you know there was a natural sense
you know to kind of balance it but like
I say it's just the pendulum has gone
too far and I think what's happened is
people have just lost their balls people
are not courageous enough to say enough
you know men and women come together and
say it's enough it's gone too far
everybody is suffering how can we do it
together and we've created this
polarized world where everyone's on each
other's backs you know men against women
black against white rich against Paul
and no one's come together and say what
kind of society do we want to live in
and how courageous do we need to be to
create it it's not going to be perfect
and there's always going to be losers
but we need to create this because
everyone's suffering but no one's doing
that and it feels like society and the
powers that are be have created this
like what you just said pal I mean the
fact that you've got rumble on standby
just shows there's a lot of I know you
have a lot of your detractors a lot of
your hates I get it but there is
something really important about what
you're trying to say same way Kevin
Samuels God Rest his soul there's a lot
of stuff that people are trying to say
but the minute they say it they're shut
down but we need to hear his point of
view how can we say it when there's so
much things coming out like it's like
now you have to think of it well not in
my world but now it's not just male and
female there's like all the in between
sectionality exactly so how can we even
but no one's waiting everybody stop and
let's do it this way or let's try today
we can't because we've got to think of
this one this one and this one do you
know it is it's almost like the majority
of people are sensible thinking but
people are scared and I think we're
letting the agenda be run by the
fringersexual people like how what
percent of people are even or even trans
or he she whatever the hell it is it's
like it's like what one two percent of
the population and we all have to cater
to them yeah yeah the kids in the
schools yeah that's how it's well not in
the real world but I feel like on social
media that's what they're catering to
it's like in the schools I'm I'm scared
to you know have my kids go to to actual
school I'll home school my kids if by
the time I have children there's certain
because I don't want them to think
that's okay I don't want them to think
yeah I don't want them to like for
example like Peppa Pig right this is
gonna sound so random but about two
months ago I saw in Peppa Pig they
changed it it was like same-sex sort of
thing and I don't have
a problem or whatever with same-sex or
lesbian or whatever but my child's
seeing that and said like a mummy and a
mummy can't have a baby like that's the
reality well it's like why do they need
to know why do they need to know that
they're so innocent like they just if
they're if they want it's exactly like
now it's more like fours fours not
saying that I'm against anything no I'm
just saying now it's more pressure and
it's popular yeah yeah it's a trend it's
a trend to be bisexual there's so many
girls I know especially like our age
group like 21 is like yeah I'm bisexual
black is a trend you know so
so um
guys what is more important to you when
looking at a guy
money or looks
I have a third one I'm not gonna lie
yeah yeah
money money yeah no but if I say money
it's gonna sound like I'm a gold digger
don't worry about it
I'm gonna be real let me keep it real
baby
money oh my God yeah same money yeah
definitely so if you were advising guys
would you tell them to get their money
up first or their Fitness if they only
had time for one oh Fitness oh sorry no
money but I'm just I'm just curious if
the results you guys have seen are the
same what's interesting for me like I
was bringing this up on the King
Richard's podcast yesterday is that I've
had tons of broke clients that spent the
last of their money on my training and
got rock star level results like just
getting tons of girls living at home
like doesn't matter like I found that
money is very very very like almost
irrelevant really as long as the guy's
not living in poverty I know online like
everyone thinks so true there's like so
many red book creators that are like get
the bag and all this stuff but in
practice that's total BS but don't you
think money makes a guy more confident
and more like worthy for I get the other
side of the coin though I get a lot of
like millionaire clients I haven't had I
was telling you before the show a
billionaire client and they're just
trying to lead with that right so
they're like I'm just gonna pick her up
in the Ferraris
a guy being in touch of his
masculinities what makes him attractive
and he doesn't need money
yeah
money or looks yeah
exactly yeah but one thing also when
first of all money can just tell you
more about his ambition yeah it's up to
something Fitness is more important than
money for sure because your body your
health will give you everything mental
health you can have the money today you
lose it tomorrow and you will be left
alone with the girl that you picked and
you'll be with the man that you picked
and it's a duty to work a life together
that's a commitment I should agree that
if your guy was unemployed he only has
so much time before you would leave yes
or no no depends on the contest so like
like let's say five years no job well
that's a bit crazy like no job at all
I need I I believe that
the man is the lead like he is the one
that takes charge and if
he doesn't hold that up I just feel like
I couldn't stay with someone that's just
there needs to be a drive when you're
working there's a drive there's a
motivation like you're working I'm
working like we're in this together like
I couldn't be with a man that's just
that's no motivation for me that's just
being lazy I think I'm being honest I
think it depends you know because it
depends if he's willing to work if he's
motivated to work whereas if he's not
motivated and he's fine he's just
chilling with no job no money for five
years and it's a bit of a problem but if
he's motivated he knows what he wants to
do he's just working towards his goals
or he's willing to back towards his
goals then I feel like that's okay like
we've all taken time out for ourselves
but like obviously everyone's different
and we're all quite young as well like
no no I don't believe that everyone has
their own opinion like a side Hustle
a part-time job would you say would you
say a side hustle
um pal is um a job would you class is
the same thing aside hustle on a job
so for example like early fans
I mean it's a jar it's still a job
um for a man not for a guy
um
I think it's a job it's not a career
okay yeah it depends it depends on the
side hustle yeah it's yeah it's a broad
yeah it's a very broad yeah this is an
extreme example too right like there's
like gradients like are you talking
about like does a guy need to be rich
versus like have just enough no you're
talking about like unemployed right my
only point was at some point if he if
he's not making enough money we're gonna
leave yeah that's at some at some right
yeah no I'm gonna agree with that but
I'm saying like the guy has like his
basic needs mat yeah like I found it
doesn't really make much of a difference
if he has like a ton of money except for
certain girls not in the room like
jobless what's the difference okay is it
different in the Eastern European
countries versus the West yes I mean in
terms of money yeah I mean yeah because
most people are poor right like like in
in Ukraine and in Poland even in Brazil
like people are making
like a thousand dollars a month or less
so like you know it's like 10 grand a
year or less than 10 grand a year after
taxes so I mean you know it goes back to
those his basic needs met right if basic
needs are met I haven't found that it
makes much of a difference because I've
had so many rich clients that are all
clueless like they're all in their their
like millionaire circles and like hey we
thought this would get us the girls and
we got all the money and there's no
girls and then I have clients that have
hardly any money that just Crush once
they're doing things right and the girl
doesn't even know they don't have money
but again like we're talking about like
unemployed like completely broke for
years versus at least having basic needs
met like a lot of guys like even if
they're not doing super well it wasn't
statistic it's like 80 of people are
living paycheck to paycheck in the US I
think is something like that so that
high wow I'm pretty sure yeah so it's
like if they don't get paid one week
they can't pay the bills but that's like
almost all guys right so all this like
focus on oh you need to go make a lot of
money and there's a lot of creators that
say like forget dating just go focus on
making money when they arrive at the
money if they ever do most of them don't
even get the money but if they do it's
not like girls just start raining down
in their lap